a large part of what you talk about is  grounded in the reality that men or men  women are women they're different  what do you think this newfound Embrace  of gender activism and gender fluidity  and a man can become a woman and a woman  can become a man and people can wake up  every day and identify as something  different what do you think the goal is  here with people who are really  advocating for that right now the goal  okay so there's the personal level and  then there's sort of like the  socio-political level here I think on a  personal level men and women want to  feel special in some way it's no longer  enough to be homosexual to make you  special now you've got to be transgender  to be special there has to be some sort  of something that makes you unique and  there has to be some sort of tribalism  that's attached to that and in order for  that to be effective uh you have to  convince a society at large to play  along with your psychosis and that's  really what it is